so here we have a sample of titanium
wire titanium is a really quite
fantastic metal it's very very
lightweight and very very strong it's
used in construction materials very low
concentrations and as additives for
alloys titanium is a very light metal
and very strong it's used sometimes in
the aircraft industry it can be used in
chemical reactors it has the rather
unfortunate tendency that
high-temperature it can burn so you have
to be careful or your chemical plant
could burn down so we're going to open
it now we'll hopefully see the titanium
wire around the spindle so you can see
it's a really quite beautiful dark
coloration there is a feeling that if we
could make cars out of titanium they'd
be much lighter than our current cars
made out of steel and therefore we would
use less petrol driving them around the
problem is that titanium at the moment
is very difficult to make the
manufacturing process is very expensive
and therefore using it widely is not yet
an option but it's very common material
it's found widely in in the environment
and you looking around the room you're
sitting in will probably see titanium
because the oxides titanium dioxide is
the pigment we used in what white paints
so all around here that all the white
paint is titanium dioxide very beautiful
sample often used as well in the
construction of aerospace shoulders sort
of capsules and components to go into
space because it's light and strong and
some titanium dioxide has an interesting
property that if you shine light on it
it becomes quite reactive but without
dissolving and so there is the idea of
using titanium dioxide for purification
of water that you will shine light onto
the titanium dioxide powder and that
this will then react with impurities in
the water and produce clean water merely
using solar energy so there's titania